[Music]
a shooting star crashes on earth and a
hideous blob emerges it creeps and leaps
it glides and slides it's also
unstoppable weapons fire extreme
temperatures no matter what you throw at
it it just regrows and continues its
rampage its expansion is breathtaking it
doubles in size every hour but there is
one opportunity after each hour it goes
to sleep forming itself into a flat
triangle and resting for a few minutes
before it begins
eating and growing again your only
chance to save the planet involves a
satellite mounted nano fission ray that
can cut through the blob when the blob
is active it heals itself within seconds
however when you break the sleeping blob
into two triangles you make a critical
discovery the acute triangle portion
with all angles less than 90 degrees is
inert it never wakes up the obtuse
triangle which has an angle greater than
90 degrees wakes up as usual and keeps
growing similar experiments show that
all shapes other than acute triangles
including right triangles will also wake
up for the next few minutes the blob is
sleeping in its obtuse triangle form you
can make clean straight line cuts
between any two points on or inside the
triangle but you'll only have time to
make seven cuts while the satellite is
above you by the time it completes its
orbit and returns the blob will have
consumed the entire world if even a
single portion that will wake up remains
how can you cut the blob entirely into
acute triangles and stop it from
destroying the planet
while this seems doable at first
there's a hidden difficulty when it
comes to avoiding obtuse and right
angles every time you make a cut that
reaches an edge it either makes an acute
and an obtuse angle or two right angles
that makes it seem like you're doomed to
keep creating obtuse angles but as with
so many of life's problems we can look
to pizza for inspiration
imagine squaring off the outside of a
pizza so that instead of a circle it's
an octagon when we cut it into slices
each of the eight triangles is acute
this works with larger polygons too
importantly it also works for some
polygons with fewer sides including
heptagons
hexagons and pentagons that's good news
because if you cut off the sharp corners
of the blob triangle a Pentagon is
exactly what you'll be left with and
just like a pizza you can cut the blob
Pentagon into five acute triangles
that's seven cuts and it renders the
blob completely inert you've saved the
day now you just need to figure out what
to do with all of these giant
practically indestructible triangles
here's a bonus riddle for you our
triangles the best shape just kidding
that's not a riddle but it is worth
discussing watch these lessons and
decide for yourself
[Music]